Oi hoje quando acordei 6 horas da manhã
eu tava vendo um jornal esse uma notícia
nos últimos sete anos subiu 40 porcento
o número de infectados de HIV e AIDS de
jovens
E aí eu fiquei assim nossa alguma coisa
que eu vou lavá-la Veja essa notícia
bombástica né e eu queria que vocês
tenham faça um pouco sobre quantas
pessoas hoje estão vivendo com HIV e
AIDS não nós tem um relógio nas Nações
Unidas que ele funciona online o tempo
inteiro contabilizando o número de casos
de pessoas que contraem vírus Então hoje
às seis da manhã e 136 a gente tinha 40
milhões 596 1.724 pessoas vivendo com
HIV e AIDS e o que que você soubesse que
a cada 12 segundos uma pessoa comprar
vir você vai ver e a cada dezesseis
segundos a gente tem um óbito
E aí
o que eu tive três encontros a minha
vida que me fizeram chegar nisso que eu
sou hoje é meu primeiro encontro tive um
encontro com o artista plástico Fabiano
menina que ele fazia uns colares com
preservativo que chamava você que
tendências para o sexo Aquilo me chamou
atenção isso foi 94 20 anos atrás você
já era ativista do Greenpeace eu entrei
na Greenpeace com 11 anos lá então com
15 eu já tinha minhas atividades bem
fundamentadas em tudo bem E comecei a
perceber em Florianópolis na limpeza das
praias muito preservativo no chão
eu fui no segundo sinal de quem que você
tá bom hoje está cheio de ativista mas
acho que tem uma outra causa que eu
posso me dedicar um pouco mais se foi
trabalhar no gata o grupo de aplicação
aérea de Florianópolis como voluntária
trabalhando com crianças vivendo para
dar ideais que foi meu segundo encontro
quando eu ganhei uma caixa com 144
preservativos ela falou assim Ah Adriana
você pode usar esse preservativo fazer
alguma coisa a gente tem uma campanha
primeiro de dezembro gente vai fazer
distribuição na rua então vou customizar
umas peças para chamar atenção então
vamos lá para Rua não é um vestido com
meia dúzia de preservativos minhas
amigas vão fazer um desfile fomos para
um bar se chama um bar no bairro 1500
pessoas uma festa primeiro de dezembro
vamos
e vem com tempo eu fiz um vestido e
concorriam concurso de fantasia e ganha
1º lugar como a personalidade feminina
eu sempre veio uma ansiedade de pensar
onde tem essa matéria-prima da onde que
ela vem se eu consigo mais e comecei a
minha pesquisa sempre pensam chegar a
lugar nenhum três Sem interesse que me
veio pela camisinha descobri que a gente
tinha cinco Fontes né como ativista do
Greenpeace Tira toda minha preocupação
ambiental o que que era feito com esse
desgaste então nós temos preservativos
que não passavam no controle de
qualidade e que na época ego encerrados
né não viu de agradável nós tínhamos a
falha de produção da indústria Nacional
inverno que não se reaproveita vacina
erava a gente tinha os apreendido em
contrabando que entravam no país e
legalizados e tinha que se dar um
destino para ir se passou e cenário e a
parte de teste de laboratório né peço
gestor o teste de qualidade e também não
sei muito o que fazer com isso esse
negação. Vou para São Paulo
eu não sei que peguei da Saúde tive um
encontro maravilhoso com Mari
pneumologista Rodrigues Munhoz ela falou
assim eu vou te dar uma caixa com duas
mil novecentos e noventa e duas
camisinhas e os Uau que que eu vou fazer
com tudo isso eu não tenho nem lugar
para guardar tudo isso e fiz a primeira
peça que foi um vestido e um Tiago não
que na época o caso é o apresentador da
MTV resolveu fazer um telegrama vestiu a
peça Sabrina pagar o Tony também fizemos
uma ação e de ação veio meu percurso foi
para um Jô Soares nesse jogo recebi ele
mil telefonemas do país inteiro me
chamando para fazer eventos
Olá eu sou vamos lá foi para Maceió pela
Secretaria da Saúde fez as primeiras
peças vestidos de numa a popular de
Maceió um desfile com distribuição de
camisinha é com a MTV filmando um super
evento e sempre ligadas na questão de
uns números de casos estão subindo é que
ele Pânico total né e o estigma e como
os as pessoas vivem com HIV as eu até
então não tinha um contato pessoal
íntimo mas eu vim a ter esse contato
dois anos depois isso me deixou arrasada
a família arrasada um assunto proibido
não se pode falar eu se assim não agora
vou assumir isso eu vou entrar numa
Fundação e eu vou fazer um trabalho
assistencial em escolas Periferia e
penitenciárias e comecei a trabalhar
numa penitenciária peguei esses
o preservativo a sua ansiedade de
enquanto artista de transformar
multiplicar manusear a tocar de já tinha
necessidade de fazer coisas maiores aí
foi para a tela não tinha de guardar as
camisinhas vezes uns puffs de camisinha
vai a minha casa toda não tinha um sofá
só tinha Puff com os preservativos
dentes então é a recebendo e aguardando
EA reaproveitando e lá estava eu até
minha cama com colchão feito de
preservativos é daí vocês tapetes enfim
é uma série de experimentos artísticos
experimentos me levava uma conferência
em 2001 Barcelona conferência mundial de
prevenção de AIDS Neve onde eu tive um
presente que foi uma visita do Bill
Clinton E o Nelson Mandela
e foi um conta que é demais pra minha
cabeça na hora de nossa assim a gente
quer que você faça parte da fundação que
você tem o seu trabalho associado a
gente qual que é o seu projeto Qual que
é sua ideia mesmo sem Olha primeiro eu
queria te dizer que foi muito difícil
para mim chegar com um preservativo
dentro da minha casa
e as pessoas escondem no supermercado
ele a trancado com cadeado na farmácia
ele era hoje ele aberto a existe o
supermercado ainda que eu pegava tiver
fechado junto com outros produtos eu
disse eu queria é desmistificar isso né
Eu acho que se a gente não tiver
intimidade com objetos a gente não
conhecer não manusear não testar como
incorporar Isso numa cultura e fazer que
uma população multi comportamento e
começa a usar o preservativo na hora que
precisa daí eu comecei a fazer várias
experimentos né com a questão da
identidade da moda e o as roupas seguem
as conceituais esculturas enfim até que
determinado momento conheci o o ator
Richard irem na Tailândia 2004 nesse
processo acabei viajando muito mundo eu
cheguei no mundo
e deve ser a lei eu sei mercado nenhuma
Brasil mas um convite Uma demanda fora
muito grande de falar de uma forma
diferente eu pego você viu gente eu acho
que eu tô criando uma ferramenta para
que educadores e educando os pais mães
comunidade posso introduzir o
preservativo dentro do núcleo familiar
desisti chega matizando e falar de
efetivamente a prevenção
eu conheço eu consegui fazer uma série
de Arte Shopping no Brooklyn em Nova
Iorque um grupo de judeus muçulmanos
árabes católicos protestantes tinham 15
integrantes nesses oito shots de cada
comunidade e ele ia me deu uma vontade
de fazer um homework um dever de casa só
olha você vai chegar com esse
preservativo na sua casa é você vai
falar para o seu pai para sua mãe para
quem cuida de você cria uma peça com
esse 53 negativos e amanhã você me traz
estou de volta
e você fica uma carta formal para poder
entrar naquela família sem agredir sem
ficar um problema me veio várias
experiências pais com recusas claro né a
críticas mas eu perceber que podia ir
mais além eu vamos voar atenção mais se
dever de casa na comunidade então com
filho os pais parentes tem que fazer
alguma coisa com seu vizinho
E aí foi lá o vizinho envolvido nem me
trouxe um feedback também nem sempre
positivo Mas o importante é que ele
entrava e me trazia um retorno Esse é o
ponto entrou a discussão entre a
temática EA gente consegue discutir isso
de forma mais bem-humorada né e sem
tanto preconceito e nesse processo todo
são 20 anos trabalhando com isso é 21
museus então Europa EA Ásia Américas
chega fazer projetos em museu mundial
das culturas na Suécia onde eu vou virar
escola comunidade onde eu desenvolvo as
peças com a mão de obra dos beneficiados
nos oito shops e hoje que a gente que eu
não sou mais artista agora eu sou um
pano de fundo para uma discussão então
onde eu vou leva os likes leva as ideias
dirijo confecciona estendo esse diálogo
não só uma comunicadora Dede alguma
Bom dia você me dava um resultado e esse
resultado geralmente são desfiles falar
8 Shop Zé Exposições onde essas peças
ficam para aquela comunidade e elas
acabam usando isso ano ano nos seus
próprios eventos então o que que eu faço
retomando a transforma porque ativos que
não passaram no controle de qualidade
Seja lá qual a fonte em um objeto de
arte para o mundo uma reflexão crítica
contemporânea e multidisciplinar do que
essa obra Keller ela quer falar sobre
estética sobre medo sobre que Tabu sobre
o estigma ela quer provocar uma mudança
de comportamento é
e daí quando eu li essa notícia hoje eu
vi o jornal subiu quarenta por cento de
infecções
O que que a gente tá fazendo nós somos
os primeiros no mundo em tratamento de
HIV e AIDS no Brasil e que a gente como
que a gente está educando os nossos
educadores como os nossos educadores
Estão levando isso para os seus alunos
tá então eu tive um ano frustrante No
Brasil onde eu tentei em uma série de
workshops dentro de um Sindicato de
escola particular e introduzir a
temática e eu fiquei esperando um ano e
encontros pontuais tudo educadores eu
não tive um educador interessado
eu tentei parcerias com o estado governo
Ah não você artista é você não é
Educadora é você não é longe não não
soube eu ajudo as ondas são artistas são
ativistas né
a ver com isso é um trabalho de
formiguinha eu tô conseguindo levar
conseguir levar isso era mais ou menos
65 países ao vivo onde eu estive no
Brasil Ainda estou engatinhando tô
tentando entrar nesse mercado que é o
meu país que eu acho importante que não
é porque a gente tem o melhor tratamento
do mundo que a gente que a gente tem que
ser o exemplo em prevenção também né e
semana que vem já começa um novo ciclo
com os educadores americanos uma
conferência de educação sexual onde eles
reconhecem essa temática como ferramenta
Onde Eu Venho multiplicadores eu dou as
técnicas do a fonte E compartilhe eu
acho que o grande trabalho nisso é o
compartilhar esta ferramenta né
e daí agora eu queria que você refletir
ser um pouco sobre quantas pessoas se
infectaram quem tem noção de quantas
pessoas tem que ter que pagar durante um
pouquinho tempo que eu falei
e nós tivemos 90 infecções e sessenta e
sete óbitos Qual que é o meu papel nisso
eu fico pensando o quê que me inspira
quem nesse Tive que me leva o que que me
move são os adolescentes são os idosos
são as pessoas que eu amo são as pessoas
que estão na volta fica eu acho que
viver com estigmas hiv-aids ninguém
merece isso tem que mudar paralelo é
isso eu tenho um outro trabalho que eu
sou porta-voz uma campanha da Anistia
Internacional que luta pelo fim da
mutilação genital feminina onde nós Já
conseguimos o asilo político EA mulheres
em risco e mulheres que foram mutiladas
na Europa em toda Europa onde eu também
faço um trabalho plástico claro que a
gente a gente faz uma pétala de Rosa
impressa no papel e colheu assinaturas
em toda a união europeia Edilson
transformada em obra de arte para
discutir o tema também como a visão mais
positivistas sem tanto medo sem tanto tá
bom e a gente tá
a campanha ação na justiça dois anos
representando os animais tom de voz da
campanha
Oi e essa é o meu trabalho de artista e
ativista senhor são esses problemas de
ordem social que me interessa obrigado a
E aí